take make use and dispose for decades
this is how companies have been taking
raw materials and transforming them into
products purchased by consumers who
ultimately toss them out but now people
are challenging this linear model and
urging the so-called circular economy so
how is a circular economy different from
recycling the two ideas are related but
a circular economy is more systemic and
ambitious than a linear one most
recyclable products in a linear economy
ultimately get downgraded into waste but
in a circular economy no new material
input is needed that leads to less waste
and ultimately reduced costs the linear
economy often leads to a system that is
inefficient and costly and depletes
natural resources a byproduct of this is
material waste which takes up space and
may include contaminants threatening
biodiversity but still making a
production cycle fully self-sufficient
is virtually impossible some new input
will always be necessary some wastes
will always be created building a
circular economy also requires High
upfront costs
and some say a circular economy will
only ultimately delay the negative
environmental effects of the linear
economy consumers are largely
responsible for pushing organizations
towards the circular economy and can get
companies who invest in more circular
Supply chains for example SC Johnson and
son and Unilever are developing
refillable packages for cleaning
products and laundry detergents
governments also have a hand making
cross-border commitments and developing
action plans to move toward a more
circular economy so slowly we're seeing
people become more and more conscious
and they are challenging the
sustainability of the linear economy
model
foreign